hi Matt Welch here on ask a libertarian
day with my co-author Nick Gillespie of
the Declaration of Independence we are
now moving to the ask a libertarian
lightning round first up serious man
what should the new NHL team moving to
Winnipeg formerly known as the Atlanta
Thrashers be named I'm going with the
unfortunate okay then Florida double
blue ass when does the political
vomiting stopped never especially if you
watch Republican presidential debates
forest McCracken asked Matt how do you
feel about the death penalty with
regards to Dave Henderson I have been an
anti-death penalty advocate for about as
long as I've been an angels fan so I'm
very conflicted on this issue ultimately
if we're going to kill people make them
Boston Red Sox first Nick from poker
grump since Social Security actually I'm
going to answer this one since social
security is a failing pyramid scheme why
can't a congressman say so without
getting grief well actually people are
saying so right now without getting
grief Paul Ryan's saying so Rand Paul is
saying so there is a politics available
in this country at long last for
campaigning on something approaching
reality when it comes to entitlements i
will ask this one too you know New York
conservative jg alts Nick do you see any
reason to be optimistic about the future
of the United States yeah I mean at the
the least I say about 300 million
reasons to be optimistic or whatever the
population is people like Julian's
assignments that are the ultimate
resource most of them are not bad people
but when you look at the production and
consumption of art when you look at
lifestyle tolerance a lot of things
coming up roses amen and finally MC
Moynihan also known as Michael Moynihan
via Twitter is it all just a game it is
all just a game but it's a game that we
can't win
you